ونتابع اذا المزيد من التصريحات لوزير
التعليم العالي لطالبان لو القوا علينا
قنبله ذريا لن نتراجع عن منع تعليم النساء
ونشاهد وزير التعليم العالي لطالبان يتحدث
اذا في هذه الصور التي تصلنا من هناك وهذا
التصريح القوي بخصوص عدم تراجع همم طالبان
عن منع تعليم النساء رغم كل التمديد
الدولي يقول لو القوا علينا قنبله ذريه
فلن نتراجع كان قال ان طالبان مستعده
لعقوبات عليها من المجتمع الدولي همم حتى
همم يعني على اثر هذه القرارات ولكنها رغم
ذلك لن تتراجع عنها كانت منعت النساء من
التعليم الجامعي اذا كانت منعتهن ايضا من
الانتساب والعمل في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
همم بعضها اوقف عمله في الداخل الافغاني
مع الكثير من التاثيرات السلبيه كان كام
على المراه او على المجتمع الافغاني لان
هذه المنظمات لها باع كبير في العمل
الانساني والاغاثه في الداخل الافغاني